hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from around 500 to
2019 Sinquefield cup it's a yummy pony
versus Hikaru Nakamura a true
theoretical struggle with a lot of
action going on I'm sure gonna enjoy it
but before we check out the actual game
I would just like to say that we are you
know coming really short with the quotes
that I used above the board so for the
next few videos if you feel like it
you're welcome to suggest quotes they
don't have to be quotes about chairs
they can be quotes about you know some
weiss quotes about life about pretty
much anything they can be funny they
don't have to be even by famous people
they can be your own quotes if you enjoy
them so you know feel free to suggest
quotes so we you know freshen things up
a bit
now that being said let's dive straight
into the game napa opens with the white
pieces he plays d4 we have Knight to f6
c4 e6 you all know this is going into
the Queens gambit declined we have d5
Knight to c3 and now Bishop to e7 not
going for the ragas in defense like Gary
did against the ding in the game we've
previously shown with the shop to f4 and
now castles with III and the now c5 this
is a very popular line D captures Bishop
captures and now C captures on d5 in the
Grantchester in Paris in the blade
section and Mamedov played a three
against Nakamura and mom Dara was able
to win that game but here Anna prefers C
characters on d5 we have Knight captures
on d5 and Knight captures he captures
black now has an isolated the d5 pawn
and we have Bishop to d3 here so Bishop
to b4 check first creating disorder
amongst the whites pieces with Knights
to d2 and here Napo already had this
position against Nakamura it was in the
cote d'ivoire Abidjan blitz tournament
where d4 was played by nakamura but here
nakamura doesn't see d4
as a fit move for a classic game so here
he continues Knight to c6 just
developing with castles by Neto and bush
of the back to e7 now that the knight is
no longer pinned we have rook to see one
nicely developing and here nakamura
already had this position against
Magnus Carlsen in that game he played
better up to f6 I was in also in the
scene iv Cup but in 2017
he attacked the BT up on that game ended
in a draw but it's interesting that
Bishop to f6 is the engine's third
recommendation whereas the move Nakamura
plays in this game Queen to b6 again
eyeing the BTO pawn is the engines first
recommendation so improving on the 2017
line he played against Carson or maybe
he played it against cars in 2017 you
know on purpose maybe thought that
Carson knows the the best continuation
by heart and maybe he doesn't know the
Bishop f6 line so who knows and here
there is a one game that reached this
position it was Alexander Grisha versus
Vishwanathan Anand in the 2018 includes
blitz tournament where Knights the B 3
was played by Greece off to defend the B
to pawn but here
Knepper goes Queen to c2 it's a new move
and as a move 14 we have a completely
new game so this is where the fun starts
the b2 point is protected and also the
Queen Bishop battery is now attacking
the h7 points so here Nakamura probably
doesn't know this position as it never
happened before and he doesn't like g6
just defending or h6 just giving the
bishop pair some targets so instead he
plays a very interesting move he plays
Knight to be 4 just attacking the Queen
and the bishop now I haven't seen the
interview after the game or I haven't
followed their live coverage so I don't
know if Nakamura blundered upon here or
he thought that Knepper just can't grab
the h7 point but this is exactly what
napadas he played Bishop CAD for some h7
with check King to h8 and now what do
you do with the bishop if you don't do
anything for example if you play your
queen is under attack
like Queen B 1 you get g6 and your
bishop is trap next move black will just
capture it you can't even win 2 points
because the black will not capture with
the f1 black to capture with the Queen
and you don't have compensation for a
sacrificed piece so there is a move
napal can play to save his bishop so
it's a good exercise feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this idea
how nipple saves the bishop it's really
a beautiful idea that allows him to keep
his extra pawn
while I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are really a
magnificent player and for those who
just want to enjoy the movies Queen to
c7 your bishop is under attack but black
Bishop is also under attack here so the
continuation goes Queen captures on c7
not rook captures on c7 you have to keep
the bishop on e on e7 unfree and now
Bishop to d8 you had to see all of this
to be able to save your bishop now
Bishop to d6 this is the move and this
is what I will be using for the
thumbnail as it's just beautiful
so here Nakamura has to decide whether
he wants to trade everything with King
captures on h7 Bishop character son f8
captures on c7 and capture son before he
goes into this position where he at
least he took away an it was a bishop
pair but he is down upon although he
just lost upon there is no way around it
but he decides to keep more material on
the board keep things a bit more
complicated but the disallows nipple to
keep his bishop pair he played Bishop
captures on c7 with Bishop captures on
f8 and now a5 defending the knight and
now nepo just retreats Bishop back to be
one guarding the a to pawn with Bishop
to e5 by a Nakamura now going after the
B to pawn but now just b3 and here in
Bishop to g4 nicely developing the
bishop pair also creating an attack
opening up an attack towards the bishop
on f8 so the Shabak the c5 and now rook
the c8 again going for the bishop and
Bishop to b6 so here never kept his
bishop pair he is still an upper pond
and here Nakamura finds a very
interesting more how to grab the a to
pawn with Knight captures an 8 to
bushel characters and a 2 and rook to c2
now with a double attack so temporarily
a piece sacrifice but of course Nakamura
can win it back whenever he wants do now
of course it seems logical to go Bishop
to be 1 here you give up the night on d2
and then you grab the a 5 point for
example rook after sandy - you capture
on a5 but the problem is rook to be 2
goes after the b3 point and you can't
defend it you can't go Bishop
anywhere and if you push before then you
run into Bishop to e2 and now if rook e1
then just lose material a bishop C 3
followed by Bishop to b2 and if you go
rook the c1 then g6 this just makes a
whites light square bishop a terrible
piece
there's no way to develop it and this
Bishop is really terrible just stuck
there on a5 guarding the b4 point so
even though black is down upon black is
actually better here and you will not be
able to hold on to your b4 pawn for very
long so although Mishra b1 seems like a
natural move Knight f3 is better this is
what an apple plays goes after
Nakamura's undefended bishop on e5 and
here Nakamura has the trade Bishop
captures with G captures on f3 rook
captures an 82 now defending the e5 pawn
and now rook to d1 and here you can see
just how weak a nakamura
pawn structure is this pawn is weak then
this point becomes weak yeah you can
tell our rook captures on d5 so instead
well you could go rook to be to try and
trade but you will have to wait because
then rook captures the bishop is under
attack this point becomes under attack
so here nakamura decided to play rook a
1 he decided to go into this endgame
being down upon nappa says all right
with rook a personally won Bishop
captures anyone and now Bishop captures
on a5 so it's 5 points against 4 we
entered the endgame so let's see how
they play it out with f5 by Nakamura and
King f1 neppo starts bringing in the
King into the game and it's a very
instructional end game so if you like
hand games you're really going to enjoy
this
King g8 now King key to both players
have to improve under King's activity
King of 7 with King to d3 and now not
the automatic King e6 if King e6 you
lose the game because well now the King
can support a bunch of Bishop c3 and you
lose you have to trade bishops and now
it's a king and pony endgame where well
Europe upon it's a winning endgame so
not the automatically six Bishop to e5
getting the Bushra back to safety net
poor tries to trade over the bishop of
course nakamura declines it and it's
very interesting you can't even capture
on h2 if you capture on h2 another very
nice line f4 just trapping the bishop
now you can just go after it and capture
it and of course if you play g5 to
freedom Bishop then just GF characters
and g5 you've improved White's pawn
structure you gave back the pawn and
after you save the Bishop f4 and now
it's a very nice well a very easy
endgame for white for example if a
bishop here but before you put the brush
back black can never trade bishops
Bishop c7 I would just make her way with
the king of the board force the bishop
to move even further back when material
and win the game so Bishop to d6 nipple
can't even capture the pawn or trade
bishops and now yes or no camera and now
II for my nipple with D captures only
for F captures on e4 and now again a
very interesting line again like a
nipper offers pawn capture screen
captures and Bishop captures on h2 but
again this is not possible due to Bishop
to e5 and again you you don't really
have a good move here if you go bush up
to g1 then just King to f3 and your
Bishop is trapped you're just gonna go
King G to win the bishop and of course
if we trade even though the material on
the board is equal it's a winning
endgame for black we can just quickly
show it if you start pushing this pawn
well your white will just block and then
bring the King over
win it and if you try to play on the
King set for example King g6 then you
get B for I can get five black will try
to put the Jeep on b5 g 5 b6 now and now
you will have to dominate the black King
before you go after the b7 phone for
example King G for kinky for you create
a wall here against the black King so
the black King cannot approach the white
pawn king gauge for King to f5 again
creating a wall against the black King
King h5 you're gonna go f3 again control
the black King King gauge for or H sex
doesn't really matter now we go King g5
and now you go after the b7 point and
now King gauge 5 you're gonna go King
these six King h4 King c7 are gonna go
King g3 King captures King captures I'm
just gonna move the King King c6 and
after g4 b7 g 3 and queen you're gonna
play g2 and of course this position is
winning for white I already mentioned
that a few times that
you might you maybe remember if it's a
if it's a Jeep on epon deep on or a beep
on the position is winning and of course
if it's an H point F bond C point or an
ape on then it's a draw if you don't
know this then you should definitely
study the endgame as studying the
endgame is the best so after F captures
on e4
of course you don't go for characters
and captures nakamura finds King to e6
he gives up the g7 pawn but he keeps an
eye on the e5 square with his King which
is very important with Bishop captures
and g7 now Bishop captures on h2 so you
cannot go Bishop to e5 here
now comes the ship back to d4 and here
comes b5 by nakamura with bishop to be
sorry Bishop to b6 Bishop to e5 and now
King to e3 and hear an echo is still up
upon but it's very hard to improve the
position if you just trade you're not
really achieving anything and you what
you're gonna do is improve the position
of your king so here we're gonna have a
you know a contest of bishop maneuvering
Bishop to b2 with Bishop to d4 napal
tries to trade of course you cannot
allow this with rush up to c1 and now
King to d3 Bishop back to a3 and now
Fischer back to b6 with Bishop to b2 and
now Bishop to c7 with Bishop to f6 and
now comes in Bishop to a5 just repeating
with Bishop to e5 and now Bishop to b4
we have Bishop to f6 Bishop to c5 and
now bush it back to e5 so nakamura
perfectly happy with a draw here Bishop
to e7 and Bishop to f6 and now Bishop to
d4 nipple has to be very careful so he
doesn't repeat the position three times
Bishop to e7 King to III and here Bishop
to g5 check now with f4 by neppo Bishop
to e7 trying to get an effort to push a
5 but this doesn't really work in his
favor you can't get around the deponent
alight square and then you just allow
King defies so mission back to b6 and
now Bishop to e3 with King to d3 now
comes in Bishop to c1 and Bishop ectasy
Bishop to c7 just the
the f4 point with the shabak the b2 and
now comes the bishop back to b8 push up
the f6 end now King to e3 just repeating
better back to be - Bishop to e5
offering a trade and now of course you
would be crazy to trade here even though
it seems like you're winning upon butter
now therefore captures and captures he
captures on f5 and you have to waste a
move recapturing this pawn king before
you're just gonna win this pawn get very
[ __ ] it he's just gonna win the pawn
get your king to b7 and win by pushing
da pawn
so after Bishop e5 Bishop c1 check by
Nakamura King to d3 and now for some
reason Nakamura didn't like Bishop to e3
and he played b4 here which is which is
quite quite interesting as he now allows
well for one he allows an effort to try
something different and the neppo try
something different
he plays Bishop to b8 now the difference
is this point is on a dark square so it
might seem like not a big deal because
you can always defend it with Bishop to
a3 but nipple finds a very nice
maneuvering idea now he wants to play
Bishop day 7 followed by Bishop to c5 to
tackle this pawn and well maybe even if
Bishop e3 that King can also support the
attack would came to c4 but the bishop
also has to keep an eye on the f4 point
so here it's black to move king of 6
with Bishop back to d6 now attacking the
pawn and now King the e6 again you
cannot capture because Bishop captures
on f4 so Bishop to e5 and now Bishop to
e3
we've built up the d4 and now if you
capture the you achieve nothing you just
improve the position of the White King
so you can start pushing your 5 so push
back the c1 here with Bishop to e3
offering a trade Bishop to b2 and now
Bishop to d2 hyung after this pawn
bishop to a3 now it would be interesting
but if measure up to a3 now then you get
it captures on f5 finally King captures
and King to c4 yeah just going after
this pawn and after black makes a move
with the King let's say King here then
you
kink the c5 and after king repeats King
a5 now you play Bishop characters here
and now if you traded and of course the
position if is winning and after Bishop
c1 you're just gonna go king d5 Bishop
captures Bishop c3 and this position is
winning whenever the dark square Bishop
blocks the dark squares for your pawn
you will just interpose with your bishop
wherever needed and win the game so
after Bishop DT with F captures on e4
Binaca King captures on e4 and now bush
up to a3 but now it's a similar position
King before with King f5 King d5 King f6
and came to c5 with King to f5 king b5
making black waste another move King to
e4 and only now Bishop captures and
before and now it's the same light we
already shown so naka doesn't even need
to continue this game so it was in this
position unmoved 69 that Hikaru Nakamura
resigned the game and really it's
remarkable what happened in this game
Nakamura playing that night before move
allowing nepeta Capra and a7 is what
gave nepo the possibility of playing was
something more than a draw here
but even after it's hard to say that if
even if with perfect play this endgame
is winning nepo just nipple just kept on
grinding and Indian naka pushed before
and the nipple on that game so really
really exciting but a lot of a lot of
endgame lessons to be learned in the
same game so I really hope you enjoyed
it yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual we can check to my
previous videos here but let's just
check out the standings as we haven't
showed them so far so here they are in
first three places
Fabiano corona dinkler and and
Vishwanathan island with three points
then a lot of people with two and a half
Magnus Cross and Maxim holograph Wesley
so yeah Nepal nisha sharma media of and
Sergey Karjakin
and which two points people who have
lost one game
onigiri eleven are none and he call
Nakamura after losing this game yeah I
would like to thank David Hanna for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and yeah
that's it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon with continuation of the
simple cup the cup Blanca saga and of
course checking up in York City
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day